look at how far out they're pressuring
now
and uh hawks have to make them pay and
uh i like galinari in these situations
one he can do that shoot to three
two gallo
for three strips the court
gallinari keeps it going
left alone
gallows threes here you look at these
threes they are wide open as the
kamikaze try
there by tatum
galinari from the logo yes his
confidence level
is through the roof look at these three
men's bodies up too many and so
the hawks are making them pay for it yes
they are uh-oh
sideline
is unconscious oh my goodness well they
had a mismatch there with galinary went
away from it though
now they find him right gallow will put
it up
and it is hey what you know what you're
still there finger
finger when your guy is hot lane but
look at trey finds him
step back take these three with you
williams in the corner
and turns it over yeah he saw kevin hurt
he said look you want to get into fast
breaking
uh-oh number nine yes yes
career high for danilo running the floor
look at him getting to the spot got his
hand up
he wanted
[Applause]
maybe number 10 a rhythm bounce yes
[Applause]
galanari man